explosions Rock the Ukrainian Capital
Kiev yet again on Monday President
Vladimir zielinski accuses Russia of
using so-called Kamikaze drones to
attack the city according to Ukrainian
officials at least three people died
following an attack on a residential
building authorities say Russian strikes
in other regions of Ukraine have left
several more dead and knocked out power
to hundreds of towns
a bright Autumn morning in Kiev
Shattered by more deadly attacks from
Russia
the Ukrainian Capital woke up to a
series of explosions early on Monday
morning
this residential building now a
smoldering wreck was one of several
struck at least three people are
believed to have died
as emergency teams worked to rescue
injured survivors from the rubble
shocked residents waited on news of
their family and Neighbors
we came here after getting a phone call
from our mother who said she was under
the rubble she said please find someone
urgently to help me I'm buried under the
rubble we don't know if she's still
under the rubble we were told someone
was taken to hospital it might have been
her but we don't know
Ukraine's government says the attacks
used so-called Kamikaze drones made in
Iran
they can loiter overhead before finding
and hitting a Target
surveying the damage keeves mayor Vitali
Klitschko said Moscow was deliberately
targeting civilians
they destroyed our country they
destroyed our hometown they they killed
civilians right now and we see the
everyday spare up The Stereotype is true
this true phase of this war as Russians
uh do it the Russians need Ukraine
without ukrainians and that's why they
killed civilian people
the attacks come just a week after
Russia struck key for the first time in
several months DW correspondent Fanny
fakshar reported from the aftermath of
one of the attacks
it's all clear just how many people
remain trapped here but one message is
clear Russia is not going to let go of
attacking Kiev City innocent civilians
in this indiscriminate shallings that
the people here are witnessing
the people of Kiev had gotten used to a
degree of normality in recent months but
these attacks have brought the brutality
of War rushing back
PW correspondent Matthias Berlinger told
us more about the attacks on Ukraine's
capital
yeah we had several explosions and the
most notable damage was this residential
building that was hit the three people
as far as we know died in there the the
Drone seems to have flown directly into
the frontal into this building and
destroyed the apartments in there it
might have been
targeting a power plant that's nearby
that would fit in the in the pattern
that we've been seeing that Russia is
destroying the energetic infrastructure
of the country before winter these
attacks on civilians this is the
second big attack on Cave since last
week but we've seen these drones or
we've heard that these drones were
flying towards the capital several times
most of them have been intercepted by
air defense but as we see today 40 40
drones were launched today and some of
them hit
train was able
many of the drones that were Ascend
towards the capital what does that tell
us about kiev's air defense capabilities
well air defense is of course very
important in this war because Russia has
been shooting rockets and recently
drones at civilian infrastructure since
the beginning of the war and uh the Kiev
has worked on enhancing these
capabilities and also have been
delivered some new systems but the
drones poses a certain difficulty
because they fly lower than Rockets or
planes and they it's harder to identify
them by Raider and it's more difficult
to to to hit them actually many of the
systems are even the most advanced
systems are designed to shoot down
planes rockets that fly higher and that
are bigger so
it's impressive how much can be done
already without having the proper
systems but there are systems especially
designed to shoot down drones and these
systems is what Kiev asks the partner is
now to provide Matthias it's been a week
since Russia started attacking Kiev in
retaliation for the Kirch Strait Bridge
explosion how prepared were people in
the capitol for something like this for
something like that drone strike we saw
today
everybody in Ukraine knows that anything
can hit at any time but people of course
had gotten used Kiev hasn't been hit for
many months before last Monday so people
had gotten used to that people here do
not really believe that this is a pure
retaliation for the strike on the
Crimean Bridge as it seems that there is
some plan behind it this must have been
planned before to hit all these
infrastructure objects All these power
plants must have been something they had
designed before they might have
um they might have launched it maybe or
might have planned to launch it at a
different time and might have reacted to
the strike on the Crimean Bridge that's
what people here think but overall this
is this most people here are are
convinced is something that Russia had
planned quite some time ago and there
has been some talk the city
Administration the institutions the
services are pretty quick responding and
also at clearing up the sites after any
attack also filling in
for example uh
holes in in the road we had last Monday
we had uh one one major road being hit
and it was filled up just two days later
Matthias
thank you very much
Ukraine says drones made in Iran were
used in many of Russia's recent attacks
Tehran denies selling drones to Russia
but analysts have evidence of Iranian
instructors training Russian soldiers to
use them here's a look at what the
unmanned tools of War are and what
Russia is doing with them
they call it the moped for its loud
crude mechanical noise that can be heard
from far away the Iran made Shahed 136
drone here seen hovering over Odessa
but it's no joke these drones can have
devastating effects
though Iran denies selling them to
Russia Kiev says fragments of this drone
shot down in southern Ukraine have
Iranian as well as Russian markings
the shot head is a series of drones made
by Iran the 136 has a wingspan of two
and a half meters and Carries 40
kilograms of explosives
it's classified as a loitering munition
it can hang out for hours in the air
until a Target is found then it zooms in
becoming a missile that destroys itself
on impact
what makes Iranian drones useful to
Russia is that they are cheap the shot
had 136 costs about 20 000 Euros each
[Music]
Russia flies them alone or in low
altitude swarms hoping that one or two
will get through Ukrainian air defenses
which have trouble seeing them although
several have been shot down
video
[Music]
Ukraine is still figuring out how to
deal with the threat they pose
but they will have to act fast president
zielinski claims that Russia has ordered
more than 2 000 of the shahids
earlier I spoke to olica Franco she's a
senior policy fellow at the European
Council on Foreign Relations in London
and an expert on drones and artificial
intelligence I asked her why these
Kamikaze drones are so dangerous
I think in this instance there are many
dangers because they're available and
Russia has a lot of them I was actually
really impressed by the number of drones
that Iran apparently has been able to
deliver to Russia so quickly and that
means that Russia can use them uh can
use a lot of them and can attack very
different places
um well behind the front line so nowhere
is safe basically in Ukraine and I think
that's exactly the message that Russia
wants to send um it's a it's a terror
it's terrorizing the civilians and it's
just destroying a civilian
infrastructure and though and so yeah
Russia is trying to show the ukrainians
that even far away from the front lines
they can be attacked so right now they
are plainly trying to sow fear and
Terror with this is that what you're
saying
yes I think that's that's exactly right
that's what these systems are are good
for
um and for Russia they're also I mean
they're relatively cheap
um we have a price tag of around 20 000
Euros or or
um dollars as we heard which is much
much cheaper than say ballistic missiles
or anything else that Russia has been
used to has has been using to attack
behind the the front lines and so Russia
can do this for quite a long time and if
Iran is able to indeed deliver thousands
of these systems as has been claimed
this can go on for a long time and it
also means that the Ukrainian air
defense will need to work overtime so it
just binds a lot of forces because they
will need to watch the sky all the time
and defend against these drones and that
of course makes things more difficult
for for the Ukrainian military yeah
Ukraine was able to intercept some of
the drones today but it seems Russia is
planning to step up its game even more
intending to buy more drones from from
Iran how can Ukraine go about fending
off a growing threat from the sky
yeah so I've actually been rather
impressed by the numbers of drones that
Ukraine has apparently shut down of
course it's a bit difficult to verify
but there have been pictures and videos
so it's rather clear that Ukraine has
managed to shoot down these systems with
different means so Ukraine has several
aerial defense systems most of those
aren't specifically made to defend
against drones but rather aircraft or
missile or or other things but they can
still be used against these drones
um so so that's that's good news but
there have still been quite a few that
that have gone through and it just kind
of reiterates that Ukraine is going to
need more air defenses and ideally
systems that are specifically designed
to detect and fight off these drones
because not only made the systems that
the ukrainians have not be specifically
designed for it there's also a Cost
question so you don't want to use
something where you know it costs 100
000 Euros to use it once against a
system that only costs 20 000 to the
enemy I mean you can only do this for so
long so there's a cost efficiency
question as well so Ukraine will need
more systems and will need to to keep
watching the the sky which um yeah again
kind of just binds forces and makes it
harder for Ukraine to defend on other uh
on on the front line for example
in recent weeks we've been talking a lot
about the the Ukrainian
counter-offensive and the the gains made
on Russian occupied territory what is
the increased use of these suicide
drones mean for the War and what happens
on on what parts of the country that
have become a battlefield already
hmm I mean obviously it's difficult to
to tell and we can only speculate so I
think at this point you can see that
Russia is mainly using these systems
um to to terrorize the population to
destroy or it is attack civilian
infrastructure which is gonna you know
frustrate the the civilian population
even more will destroy the economy even
more all of this has an impact on the
war although not the direct one but of
course you know you can use these
systems also directly on the battlefield
attack troop formations tanks uh Etc so
this may also uh play play a role going
forward I would be surprised if these
systems were decisive I mean there's
really one system that's decisive in in
the war
um but nevertheless I think the number
here really matters if we really are
talking about thousands
um and and Iran just keeps them coming
and Russia can throw them on onto the
battlefield this yeah this may in impact
the work quite a bit but of course you
know other elements are are important
too so let's not just focus on this one
the system it's not gonna decide the war
that was very clear only of the European
Council on Foreign Relations in London
thank you very much for coming on to the
show tonight
thank you well here in Germany Russia's
war on Ukraine was the main focus as
heads of the country's intelligence
Services gave testimony to members of
parliament today the agency said they
were well prepared to counter possible
Russian interference in Germany a key
concern is over a possible drone
Espionage Chancellor Olaf shots got a
look for himself on Monday as he visited
troops at a military training site in
Northern Germany as part of his
inspection tour he was also shown one of
the bundes own drone models
let's get more on this from our DW
political correspondent Simon young
Simon good to see you so Germany's
intelligence Services say they are well
prepared to counter possible
interference from Russia how big do they
see those threats to be
yeah I think they think they're pretty
significant the intelligence Services
say they're worried about a whole range
of potential threats particularly in
connection with Russia and I think this
uh this uh story about uh spy drones is
one of the most serious there have been
a number of reports of small drones uh
sightings of of drones operating near uh
German military bases where Ukrainian
Personnel are being trained to use the
equipment that Germany is providing to
Ukraine at the moment
and uh you know it's the the
intelligence uh authorities say that
they don't they're not able to say who's
behind those uh intrusions but they are
taking them seriously and uh stepping up
measures to uh counteract they're also
worried about uh continuing cyber
threats from Russia we've seen those uh
in the past and they also say uh that
they're taking action there I think
they're worried about disinformation
campaigns organized uh by Russia uh on
social media and we've seen examples of
that in the past and also attempts uh by
uh various Russian sources to uh you
know infiltrate the political process
here in Germany uh in particular just by
buying uh using cash to buy influence
and access I think uh in particular
there have been reports that you know
that they've been able to access that
kind of influence in particular through
a far-right uh politicians some of whom
have sort of re tweeted and cheerlead
for the Putin view of things to their
followers so there's a whole range of
threats that uh these intelligence
Chiefs are flagging up a big fear here
in Germany are attacks on the critical
infrastructure how vulnerable is Germany
in that regard
well I think we've seen a number of
things there are there have been
warnings about attacks on power plants
on the energy infrastructure and so on
what we have seen are attacks just
recently on the rail network people
cutting cables there it's a bit
mysterious again we don't know for sure
who's behind it the same with the
attacks on the gas pipelines in the
Baltic Sea recently that's been widely
blamed on Russia although I think
without clear evidence so far so I think
the authorities are worried not just
that these kind of attacks on
infrastructure could occur but also that
they could spark a wider response
particularly going into this winter we
know there are going to be problems with
energy there's going to be potentially
shortfalls in Supply price spikes and
people uh probably uh demonstrating on
the streets getting very anxious about
that there could even potentially be
electricity blackouts and I think all of
that could create an atmosphere in which
it would be rather easy for foreign
antagonists to you know use that to sort
of ferment destabilization so these are
the kind of scenarios and fears that the
intelligence Community are talking about
political correspondent Simon young
always a pleasure